so this is a weird experience for me not
something I would usually do but I'm
going to defend NBC it and it feels very
strange but maybe defend isn't the right
word instead what I want to do is lend
some context maybe you've heard this
story about Gabrielle Union who was a
judge on America's Got Talent on NBC and
then was booted off the show after the
season she did one season and then was I
guess fired and after being fired she
came back and claimed that she was the
victim of racism and and sexism and
there was a toxic work environment she
said that the environment backstage was
racist and sexist and toxic and and she
was a victim of it and it was only
because of her efforts to be a
whistleblower and clamped down on all
the racism that she was fired so fired
and then claims racism and that's the
sequence of events by the wage julianne
hough was another judge on America's Got
Talent
also an actress I think but-but-but
white and she was also booted from the
show apparently so I'm not sure if there
was racism against her as well if
there's an anti white and anti black
racism going on at NBC maybe they got
all the bases covered I don't know but
so this this has been this has been a
story's a pretty big story at least in
entertainment media and on social media
and the way that the the story is
reported and talked about it's just
Gabrielle Union was the victim of racism
stated pretty much as a fact with no one
apparently actually looking at the
claims themselves to get a read on how
legitimate they might be or might not be
and this is a lesson that a lot of
people in this country need to keep
relearning over and over again it seems
like that a claim of racism or sexism or
any other ISM or phobia cannot be taken
at face value these days ever okay I'm
not saying that it's never true maybe it
is true maybe we got ourselves a real
case of racism this is maybe this is a
tried and true is
that we've got going on here maybe but
you can never ever ever assume that you
have to look at it and so let's do that
with this story just because I think
it's a good case study of how this stuff
works so let me read now from a story in
the LA Times it says it starts with
talking about how she was fired and then
continues initial skepticism turned to
outrage with a new report from Variety
revealed ahead of the holiday weekend
that unions split from America's Got
Talent
wasn't amicable but forced after the
bring it on alum allegedly reported
toxic and racist behavior during
production the most high-profile
incident occurred when Jay Leno
allegedly made a racist joke about
Korean restaurants while taping a
segment for the show
prompting Union an outspoken advocate
for minority communities to file a
complaint with producers who allegedly
dismissed her but excluded the joke from
the final cut
the network also reportedly discouraged
union from wearing a variety of
hairstyles that had allegedly deemed too
black for viewers while Union expressed
concerns that a white contestant
overstepped while impersonating
celebrities of colors such as Beyonce
NBC in series production company
Fremantle said in a statement America's
Got Talent has a long history of
inclusivity and diversity in both our
talent and the action championed by the
show the judging and hosts lineup has
been regularly refreshed over the years
and that is one of the reasons for a
gt's enduring popularity NBC and the
producers take any issues on set
seriously okay that's pretty much it so
far those are the primary examples the
only examples as far as I'm aware of the
racism and toxicity and AGT and I was I
want to take a close closer look at
these at these claims and we'll do that
just a moment but first a word from Rock
Auto you know chain stores have these
different price tiers for professional
mechanics and then do-it-yourselfers
they've got different pricings depending
on where you fall on that spectrum but
rockauto.com prices are the same for
everybody and you also know even better
than that they're going to be reliably
low for everybody rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices pass
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear they're not
playing any games like that they're
gonna give you the lowest possible
prices rockauto.com is for everybody
doesn't require membership or account
login it's very easy to navigate very
easy to use rockauto.com is a family
business serving Auto Park customers
online for 20 years go to Rock Auto comm
the shop for auto parts and body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers they have
everything from engine control modules
brake parts the tail lamps motor oil if
you need a new carpet in your in your
car you can get that too amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need Rock Auto
comm go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck right walsh in there how did you
hear about us box so that they know that
I sent you
alright so the racism at a GT according
to Gabriel Union began with a racist
joke Jay Leno made about Korean
restaurants now let's stop there for a
moment how can a person tell a racist
joke about a type of restaurant how can
you be racist against a restaurant it is
food based racism a thing if I go to a
Mexican restaurant and I complain later
that it was a horrible place and the
food was bad have I just expressed that
that sentiment about all Mexican people
or have I said it specifically about the
food at this place and in fact if I were
to even go further than that and say
that I hate Mexican food in general and
I think it's terrible and crappy which I
don't by the way but if I did say that
is that racist against Mexican people or
is it is it is it bigoted somehow or is
it just I don't like the food by the way
the joke that that made by Jay Leno was
when he think he saw maybe it was Simon
Cowell brought in his dogs or something
or he saw a picture and the Leno said
that they look like something that
beyond the menu at a Korean restaurant
now that's about as edgy as a Leno joke
is ever going to get that's that's
edgy as it gets and it's really not that
edgy yes it trades in stereotypes about
Korean cuisine so what okay if Leno had
a picture seen I've seen a picture of a
rat and said that oh that looks like
something that they you know put on the
menu at Burger King okay
it would that be who's that racist
against in that case if you were to
trade in the stereotype that these
fast-food burger joints don't use real
beef and instead grind up cockroaches
and rats that's a stereotype
would that be racist who'd be racist
against and actually here's the thing
they do eat dogs
in Korea okay that's they do a recent
headline in USA Today says South Koreans
eat more than 1 million dogs each year
but that's slowly changing here's why
young Koreans are leading an effort to
end a centuries-old practice okay
centuries-old practice it's the first
centuries they've been eating dogs in in
Korea that's a fact it's not racist
that's it's just it's a it's a fact
about something that happens in the
world now personally doesn't bother me
either
just as a as a side note I don't you
know they want to eat dogs that doesn't
bother me yeah we cows eat dogs there's
no reason why necessarily cows should be
on the menu and dogs shouldn't it's a
cultural thing and this is an exam this
is a is this an example of and not
everything is when it comes to cultures
there are there are objectively bad
things that can happen in a culture and
we can't excuse everything based on the
fact that oh it's their culture but when
it comes to cuisine as long as you're
not eating people pretty much anything
outside of it anything outside of people
if it's part of your culture to eat that
who cares
it's just your culture we don't do it
here they do it there fine so let all
made a joke based on an actual fact
about Korean culture but actually a joke
that was about a type of restaurant and
that's racist and you Gabby Gabrielle
Union files a complaint with the
producers about the joke now we can all
kind of imagine what's happening now
because the producers get this complaint
about a joke that Jay Leno told and and
and now they're thinking oh my gosh okay
we got we got a diva on our hands here
that now this is how this is gonna go oh
man
that's what they're thinking and
probably at that moment they're already
thinking yeah we're gonna get rid of her
and once the season's over because we
can't do this I mean you can't have
somebody who's filing formal written
complaints because they hear a joke from
Jay Leno of um if you can get offended
by a Jay Leno joke that you know that's
that's like quintessential snowflake
territory if you can manage to get
offended by a joke told by Jay Leno that
they are the only thing that could be
more impressive than that as if you
could manage to get offended by it like
a Seinfeld joke which in fact people are
college campuses do get offended by
Seinfeld jokes
that's why science L doesn't do college
campuses anymore so what's next the
claim then then she she was allegedly
told that her hairstyle is too black
well Julianne Hough was also apparently
a lectured about her hair and outfits
but so the idea that it's a racial thing
seems to not hold up an anonymous
insider at NBC explained that the
complaints these women about their hair
and and what they were wearing it wasn't
raised as it wasn't sexist the issue was
continuity with how the show is
presented on the air it's not explained
what that what that's meant exactly but
I can take an educated guess and that
would be that the they shoot these
auditions over a period of days and then
they want to be able to sort of splice
them all together when they air it to
make it look like it happened in one day
which means that you need to be wearing
the same thing as a judge if you come in
wearing all kinds of crazy different
outfits it's hard to you get limits you
in post during the production phase so
they want the judges wearing the same
thing and looking the same for all of it
that's one version anyway that's you
that's one version of that the other
version is that someone came up to
Gabrielle Union and told
that her hair is too black you could you
could decide who to believe there and
then there's the final racism complaint
which is that a white contestant oh well
the exact phrasing in the LA Times
article a white contestant overstepped
while impersonating celebrities of color
such as Beyonce a different article at
Variety provides more context it says
sources also shared a related incident
that occurred during another audition
taping the season where Union and other
staffers expressed concern over a white
male performer crossing a line in
portraying people of color
the contestants gimmick involved rapid
costume changes inside a larger garment
while impersonating a multitude of
famous singers in one such quick change
the contestant emerged in the guise of
Beyonce Knowles his hands appeared as
black meant to be a character accent
three witnesses to the audition said
okay so the contestant the claim is that
the contestant engaged in black hands
not black face black hands his hands
appeared as black whatever that means he
did a bunch of costume changes and then
in one of the costumes his hands were
black now wait a second did he paint his
hands in the middle of the costume
change you ever seen these quick change
things they do on these variety acts
usually they've got multiple layers of
costumes on and they're just like
ripping one off after another so the the
hands being black that we can assume
that it wasn't painted so what was he
wearing gloves
is this a racism complaint based on the
color of gloves a contestant was wearing
now it's either that or something
similarly frivolous either way it's a
racism complaint based on the color of a
contestants hands during a quick-change
variety act I mean come on
just okay
and and yet this this is reported as
Gabrielle Union being the victim of
racism and a toxic work environment
because of a joke Jay Leno told the
color of a contestants hands while
singing a Beyonce song and the fact that
the producers didn't want her to change
her hairstyle every time she came in
look maybe a bomb will drop or something
and some detail will come out in the
future with an actual example of horrid
racism at AG T an egregious explicit
example I'm skeptical of that but maybe
you know I can't say what will happen in
the future but this as it stands right
now is just embarrassing and the fact
that the media is even reporting it is
just absurd there's nothing here and yet
if you go and google it Gabrielle Union
agt you're gonna find just hundreds of
articles reporting this there's nothing
nothing at all but some hand and you
have people on social media that share
this and and and really take part in the
spreading of fake news by propagating in
show without even taking a second to
read what the claim is because it should
it should immediately raise a red flag
when you've got something like this okay
you've got black woman a judge on a show
like a GT is all you know on the show
first season is fired then comes back
and says and portrays it as if there's
just just ramped it racism behind the
scenes well I should make you stop and
go now wait a second hey I mean they've
had other they've had other black judges
they've they're the host is a black man
you're saying it's just rampant racism
and no one's brought this up before so
it doesn't mean it's did it's not true
automatically it just it should make you
go hold on let me actually see what
they're talking about here and then if
you do that you see that oh okay well
this appear to just be total BS Wow okay
well actually it's not a wow that's
pretty much what I expected
all right before we move on a quick word
from quip quip makers of the equip
electric toothbrush want you to know
that the one single discovery that
matters most for your dental care is
simply this that that if you have good
habits then you're good you're good to
go
that means brushing for two minutes
twice a day flossing regularly no matter
what brand you use quick makes that
simple starting with an electric
toothbrush refillable floss and an anti
cavity toothpaste equips electric brush
has sensitive sonic vibrations with a
built-in timer and 30-second pulses to
guide a full and even clean the quip
floss dispenser comes with pre mark
string to help you use just enough and
plus quip delivers fresh brush heads
floss toothpaste refills to your door
every three months while while with free
shipping as well and this is all about
maintaining that routine and maintaining
those habits so that you don't fall out
of and once you establish a good habit
it's very easy to fall out of it that's
one of the things about a human fact of
human nature it's very hard to break bad
habits but it's very good it's very easy
to break good habits and that's where
clip comes in so you could join over 3
million healthy mouths and get quit
today starting at $25 that's it
and if you go to get quip dot-com slash
Walsh right now you'll get your first
refill free that's your first refill
free at get quit Cobb slash Walt spelled
GE t qu IP dot-com / Walsh quit the good
habits company all right speaking of
fake controversies I don't know if
you've caught have you caught wind of
this peloton thing there was a huge blow
up on social media yesterday over an ad
for an exercise bike and so you know
that it's something serious when it's
about an exercise bike it's an ad that
is apparently supposedly creepy weird
disturbing sexist of course any number
of other things the media has jumped in
as usual and let me give you a taste of
some of the headlines surrounding this
peloton ad for an exercise bike so many
headlines peloton faces backlash in
ridicule over new holiday commercial
peloton sparks sex is a mockery over
commercial called the gift that
gives back showing a husband surprising
his wife with an exercise bike on
Christmas morning the most disturbing
horror film of the season is peloton's
new commercial people are so confused by
this peloton bike ad everybody block
goes on from there
so let's I mean this sounds pretty
disturbing right
apparently there's a backlash sexism
horrifying horror film confusing I mean
it sounds pretty intense what could
possibly be in this ad for a exercise
bike that could justify this sort of
reaction well let's take a look at the
ad get ready watch this okay ready ride
excited let's do this five days in a row
these fries
I was totally a year ago I didn't
realize how much this would change me
thank you this holiday give the gift of
peloton hmm okay okay I gotta say I'm
not seeing it it's an ad for an exercise
bike what I what I saw all this reaction
on social media and the headlines and I
went to look at the ad I was looking
forward to it I thought well this sounds
like a pretty hilarious whatever it is
it sounds funny and then I watched the
ad and I thought what what I don't even
what exactly is the complaint here where
is the room for backlash if I wanted to
do a backlash against this convert
commercial I wouldn't even know what to
base it on like if I saw that ad and and
I said to myself I'd like to be outraged
by that which I guess is what people do
I think this is what people do in our
culture so but if I saw the ad and said
you know I I'm really in the mood for an
outrage and this I just saw this ad so
this is as good a reason as any but I'd
have to sit and brainstorm for hours to
come up with the good because off the
top of my head I can't think of one
single reason to be outraged by that
maybe it's a lack of creativity on my
part is it that the husband gave an
exercise bike to his wife as a gift is
that the thing is it is that that's not
that strange I've done that before my
wife asked for a piece of exercise
equipment as a gift she wanted it in
elliptical in this case she wanted that
as a gift and so I got her one and she
was happy was I supposed to said that
she liked this as a gift was I supposed
to say no honey I refuse on principle I
cannot buy that for you I can't I I must
not it would be wrong and be it be
immoral and actually I was I'd been
given I was given a weight bench once as
a gift I was excited about that I wanted
one I got one I can use it you know it's
a very useful thing to have some people
enjoy exercising doesn't seem strange to
me but this is how internet outrage
works again it gets kicked off by a few
people and then everybody else jumps on
the bandwagon not because they're also
outraged but but because they assume
there must be some reason even if
they're not seeing it so that the
pitchfork mob shows up at their house
and says hey grab a pitchfork we're mad
about something again oh wait what is it
this time an ad for an exercise bike
what I mean okay I guess well alright
for exercise bikes I'm so mad you don't
even know why you're mad but you just
you figured there must be a good reason
someone else told me I was talking about
this on online someone told me that the
reason the ad is weird is because the
wife is so excited about the gift about
the bike but I mean everyone you we do
all understand what an advertisement is
right it's something it's just I don't
wanna scandalize anybody but it's the
company that makes the product they they
create this ad because they want you to
buy it and so it is propaganda for the
product that's so the fact that the
character in the advertisement is
excited about the product being
advertised is kind of how advertisements
work now if you want to make fun of a
dumb holiday themed ad if you're really
if you're I think everyone we're
misdirecting our our energy here because
of course in general being upset or or
focusing on it on an advertisement for a
product around the holidays that
obviously is a good use of our energy
it's just what I'm saying is let's focus
it somewhere else so how about how about
an ad like this watch this money
No you got young only one thing's more
exciting than getting Alexis given one
Alexis December 2 remember sales event
experienced amazing at your Lexus dealer
and so that's that's one of the most
recent of those kinds of ads for the
season
you could sub in any Mercedes or Lexus
ad in December and and now here you have
a real issue which is that that car is
easily like 45 50 thousand dollars who
buys their spouse a $45,000 Christmas
gift if if I got my wife Alexis for
Christmas she would she would have me
committed it would be a crisis in our
marriage
you spent forty five thousand dollars
without talking to me first that's first
of all so what's the actual gift here
the actual gift is a nine hundred dollar
car payment congratulations honey
the only people the only way that it
could be a gift to buy a brand-new Lexus
fact a brand-new Lexus SUV for someone
has again the only way you could do that
is if you're a multi multi-millionaire
because just being a regular millionaire
still I don't think would cut it like if
I had three million dollars sit in the
bank and I bought my wife a forty five
thousand dollar gift as a car as a gift
I think she'd still be very upset so you
would need to be you know you need to be
fifty hundred million dollars deep
before I think you can start buying
gifts like that like it's no big deal
but then if that's the case why are you
running an ad like that during a college
football game it just seems I mean
that's because it's a very very specific
and niche market that you're trying to
reach and I figure you'd probably reach
them through some other means because
you don't see ads for private jets or I
don't know Butler services on TV I don't
know the companies that make like
$10,000 tins of caviar I assume they
have some way of advertising their
products I don't know how they do it but
they're not gonna advertise it during a
rerun for Everybody Loves Raymond they
have some other means of reaching their
climate bit client base I don't know
maybe they set up a kiosk at Bilderberg
I don't know what they do so the holiday
ads with giant bows on top of luxury
sedans now that's something worthy of
mockery in my opinion but exercise
equipment is pretty normal I don't know
how much these peloton bikes cost
probably way too much if you want to get
an exercise bike you could get one go to
Craigslist you can get one for 100 bucks
on Craigslist so this one's probably
what a couple thousand dollars
yeah that's expensive but it's still
something that normal people do probably
shouldn't too much to spend on a gift
but people do it alright one other thing
before we get to emails and actually
maybe staying on the theme of fake
outrage that'll be that that's the theme
of the day and also the theme of me
defending people I wouldn't normally
defend so on that note here's this you
know who Madonna is you know can you
name a van Halen
start crying now that there is this the
singer and I know who she is because I'm
pretty in tune with the youth pretty in
sync with them you might say and so
that's the singer Billy eyelash and
she's a you know very popular very
popular pop singer that I you know when
I'm when I'm when I'm connecting with
the youth when I'm trying to connect I
know - I'll go to them and say hey say
have you have you kids ever heard of the
popular singer Billy eyelash and much
like Joe Biden with his with his no
malarkey Lenore's you've seen the
picture of his actually will show that
just just as another example of
connecting with the youth here's Joe
Biden's campaign bus yeah no malarkey
an end to the malarkey and I know when
the youth of today see that bus rolling
down the street they're thinking to
themselves gee willikers that is a swell
campaign slogan anyway so she's on the
Jimmy Kimmel and she reveals that she
doesn't know who Van Halen is and this
is put her in line for derision and
mockery
almost as intense as the as the peloton
thing but this I just want to say this
is one of the lamest boomer things you
talk about an okay boomer situation this
is the classic okay boomer thing that
people do in general where we make fun
of younger people for not knowing about
something that's before their time you
ever seen those videos I just saw one a
few days ago
those videos online that crop up from
time to time of you know some teenagers
sort of very confused and trying to
figure out how to navigate a rotary
phone you ever seen one of those and you
get all these comments online about look
at these idiots don't even know how to
use a phone well it's a rotary phone
they've never seen one why would they
know how to use a rotary phone that's 16
years old no one's used one of those
things for 20 years or more 2530 so why
would they know how to use that and why
how old is Billy eyelash is what sixteen
seventy why would a 17 year old girl
what do you expect a teenage girl to be
a van Halen fan and what scenario will
she be she probably has gone her whole
life and never encountered van Halen so
what I just don't get this whole thing
it's not like look there are some things
before your time that you should know
about so if you talk to someone who
doesn't know what century the Civil War
was fought in the American Civil War
well that's a problem even though it was
before your time you need to know that
as a matter of history
now whether Billy eyelash could explain
what century the Civil War was fought in
I'm skeptical of that but you know we
want but we don't know but something
like how to use outdated technology
or facts about hair hair bands from the
70s and 80s and I know van Halen
talented musicians I don't deny that so
don't come out come at me about that I
don't deny very talented very
technically gifted musicians but I got
news for you if you didn't grow up with
that if you didn't grow up in the 70s
and 80s you're not listening to that
music probably because it's not great
and I know if you did grow up with it
then it's you've got the nostalgia and
you grew up with it
I've no problem with that I get it I
don't begrudge that but it's not like
one of those things where you know in
order to be cultured
you have to know about Van Halen who
cares you could go your whole life never
listen to a Van Halen song and you'll be
perfectly fine you'll you'll live you
could live a perfectly fulfilled life
without ever encountering hot for
teacher in fact I would even argue that
your life would probably be better if
you go your whole existence without ever
encountering hot for teacher and in fact
if you go at her life and never
encounter any hair bands from the 70s or
80s I think actually your life will be
you'll be better for it all right
that's my defense of of her let's move
on Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com
Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com this is from
broses says hi I literally just finished
watching a video on time travel and want
to know your opinion of whether it's
real or not I know it's a bit outside
politics and more cultural problems but
was just curious if they really did time
travel from the future how do we know
whether they really did or not I
definitely don't support it as a quite
scares me honestly but who are we to say
they are from the future or not I'm a
big gullible sometimes and do need
support well first of all I don't I'm
not sure if I'd called time travel a
cultural problem let's focus on the very
serious cultural problem of time travel
but it is a is something worth worth
we're thinking about anyway and as every
high school sophomore smoke
pot and his friends basement has at one
point observed we are all traveling
through time then we're all traveling
we're all when you think about it man
we're all time travelers we're just
traveling into the future at a rate of
24 24 hours a day the question is
whether the rate can be sped up or
reversed and as as for the first sped up
I think it's pretty well established
scientifically theoretically in theory
it would be possible to travel into the
future faster than we are already
traveling into the future and one way is
by traveling at an extremely high rate
of speed
this is Planet of the Apes you know he's
traveling and came back and the the
earth had fast spoiler alert but the
earth that fast forwarded thousands of
years time is relative remember and it
slows down when you're going very very
fast like at the speed of light or if
you're subject to extreme levels of
gravity that's like in the movie
interstellar where they were on the
planet with with very high levels of
gravity circling I think was a black
hole and so for every second they were
on the planet the earth aged eight years
or whatever it was so and that's all
true theoretically so theoretically if
you were to I don't know travel around
the earth a bunch of times at the speed
of light and when you come back on on
earth maybe for you you've aged 12 hours
but everyone else is aged 80 years or
whatever it would be as to backwards
time travel going at going back in the
past I don't see how that could be
possible because once an event happens
it's happened that's it there's no way
to access it it's not like it's saved on
a hard drive somewhere to go back and
revisit unless this is the matrix we're
talking about plus are all kinds of
paradoxes and well-known paradoxes like
if tonight I built a time machine and
then went back in time and gave them and
and and went up to myself at the age of
10 and gave myself a high five and then
got back in the time machine who came
back to the present
that's a paradox because that then that
means that I should have already built
it I should have already given the
high-five to myself you see
so before I even build the time machine
I should have a memory of an older me
giving myself a high-five because it
happened in the past so if I built a
time machine tonight and I go back and
interact with myself as a ten-year-old
then that event is already in the past
so it should have already happened but
it hasn't happened yet and so now we
have an event that both has not happened
yet and has already happened and and so
that's a that's an issue but thank you
for that very relevant question from
David says oh great and powerful
Overlord who reigned supreme I want to
start by saying I agree with the premise
that abortion is murder and an act of
evil and I agree with your analogy of
the lottery ticket with winning numbers
essentially being fifty million dollars
now it translates to a baby in the womb
essentially being a human life however
one thought that I couldn't get out of
my head was the pretty obvious response
a pro-abortion person would come up with
following this analogy they would say
something like well the lottery ticket
may have winning numbers and it may be
worth 50 million dollars but the winner
can still decide to rip the ticket up
and throw it in the trash although that
would make the person an idiot wouldn't
this argument hold firm I'd love to hear
your thoughts also please have mercy and
do not execute me when you take over a
supreme fascist dictator in the future -
bringing for bringing this potential
flaw in your analogy to your attention I
am but a humble servant seeking guidance
well that's true but my analogy see it's
it's that's why I said the analogy is I
think I said before I got into it it's
it's a limited analogy it doesn't
address every facet of the abortion
argument I don't think any analogy could
that's not what analogies are meant to
do so this analogy was meant to simply
address the issue of worth and I was
making the point that even if I were to
agree that a human in the womb is but a
potential person and not an actual
person even though I don't agree with
that but sake of argument if I did then
wouldn't that make this potential person
analogous to a winning lottery ticket
that hasn't been cashed in yet and which
is only potentially fifty million
dollars but for all intents and purposes
it's the same thing as 50 million
dollars and you would value it the same
so that's what I was trying to do with
the analogy I was trying to adjust
address the issue of Worth and value and
attempting to show that if we're talking
about potential worth or actual worth
it's basically the same thing now the
issue of should you have a right to kill
a child and now you're getting into
bodily autonomy and you're saying well
it's me it's so is don't I own this
child the way that I own a lottery
ticket there well then now that's a
totally separate argument now you're
getting into bodily autonomy which I've
addressed many times I'd be happy to
address again I'm not gonna do it right
here but so you just have to keep in
mind you know that not not every when
you're using an analogy to make a point
I think that can be a strong way to make
a point it's yet that it's always going
to have its limits it can't be expanded
to cover every potential objection let's
see from Rebecca says hey Matt how's the
new baby Rebecca thanks for asking the
baby is is ill-tempered definitely a
colic situation I know all parents think
that their babies have colic and we
thought that with our first three babies
because anytime they cry you know they
must be colicky but then you actually
have a colicky baby and you realize that
okay well that's what this is so that's
okay so so colic is this now I see it so
a colicky baby does three things and
three things only eat sleep and cry
that's it now you might say that that's
what every baby does but that's not
exactly true because every baby has a
fourth thing they eat sleep cry they've
also got this fourth stage or phase
where they'll just lie there quietly and
not do anything that's one of the
reasons why with a with a normally with
a baby it could be kind of easy to have
a baby around after you get past the
first couple of weeks because they don't
move they don't talk and they're gonna
spend a certain portion of the day just
kind of hanging out but you got a
colicky baby they don't they cut that
part out completely they have no use for
that and if they're awake they're going
to be vocalizing the fact that they're
awake and they're going to be crying and
you
it gets pretty intense after a while
I've had a lot of time to reflect and
meditate upon the deeper philosophical
meanings of the screams and cries of a
baby and I haven't come into any
conclusions on the deeper deeper
philosophical meaning of it because I
can't focus enough because because
they're crying all the time but I have
realized that there's definitely
something programmed into our brain to
be distressed by the sound of a crying
baby because I was think about this the
other day when when the baby was just
crying non-stop and I was thinking why
is this sound why is it so grating
because yet it's loud but that's not it
it's not just that it's loud there there
are louder sounds that are less annoying
than this there could be somebody in the
next room with a jackhammer going off
and that would be far less grating then
the baby crying so you know it's not
quite that it's not quite the pitch it's
just there's obviously something it's
programmed where we you know the sound
of a screaming infant when you hear that
sound you want to make it stop would by
meeting the the infant's needs and so
there you see obviously the the reason
why you know as parents we would need to
have that intense urge all right finally
this is from an says hi madam quite a
bit older than you so it may seem
strange to be asking your advice but I'm
hoping you could offer some insight into
my son who's a few years younger than
you we are essentially the stereotypical
adult child living in mom's basement
family although the the adult child in
this case lives in his upstairs room
upstairs we want him to move out and
start his life as a grown-up but he
can't keep a job or save money to save
his life he just has no motivation I've
heard you speak about the situation
young men are in in our culture maybe
you could offer some insight into what
my son's mentality might be why he might
lack motivation or self confidence in
this culture thanks for all you do well
and I have talked spoken many times
about the situation young men are in and
I've said that our culture is hostile to
two boys into two men and even two boys
two men but I
I'm not I don't know the specifics of
your particular situation with your son
I could only go based on what you've
said I'm not gonna give your son
that excuse though because yeah there
are challenges that men face in this
culture but you still have to face them
right and we all face it so what I would
ask about your son and I'm not trying to
be too harsh about this but what I would
ask about your son is you know yeah we
all face the challenges in our culture
men and women we all face different
challenges and yet a lot of us are still
able to get up every day go get a job go
to work take care of ourselves so why is
your son special why is it so difficult
for him why is it so much more of a
burden for him than it is for anybody
else and the answer is that it isn't
isn't more of a burden for him he's just
lazy he doesn't feel like doing it and I
want to simplify it too much but and I
you said it easier adult son you didn't
say how old he is I don't think you did
did you know so I don't know are we
talking about 19 are we talking about 29
or wait did you actually say that a few
years younger than me okay so what he's
in his late 20s early 30s I assume well
then I think it's sort of a simple
answer for you and the answer is and I
would do this right now
look after you hear me say these words I
would go to your son in his room doing
whatever he's doing and say to him okay
you are out of this house by Friday no
matter where you have to go you're done
you're out if on Saturday morning I wake
up and you're still here then you are
trespassing in my home and I'm gonna
call the police that's what I would say
and it really is that simple he has no
right to be there and still be living
off of you as an adult it's your home
not his if you don't want him there then
tell him to leave yeah he's not 9 years
old ok I'll give you got a 9 year old
that's causing a lot of problems you
can't say to the 9 year old get out of
my house right but 28 29 30 yeah it
Smith
past time for that I mean I would have
said it to him when he was 22 or 21 I
would say that when he was 20 I wouldn't
waited 10 years but that's what I would
do with him he's just you just kind of
kick him out and I know that maybe will
be difficult and he's gonna it's gonna
be a tough adjustment but at a certain
point at a certain point I think you got
to toss a kid into the cold water and
let him swim especially when it's not a
kid anymore
and especially when you're tossing him
in you know it's especially when you're
tossing a six-foot man into five feet of
water the point is he shouldn't drown he
should be able to walk in that water
it's not that hard
I mean and you didn't say I assumed your
your your child quote-unquote doesn't
have any children of his own sounds like
doesn't have a family okay you're a
single man you didn't you didn't say
anything about physical disabilities so
I'm gonna assume that's not the case
physically capable single adult man with
no dependents no kids that's the easiest
life you could possibly ask for you can
do any he could go anywhere and do
anything and get any job he wants can't
find a job here then move to move to
Texas move to North Dakota I'm moving to
California move anywhere you could go
anywhere and do anything there is
absolutely no reason for an adult who is
physically very physically capable
mentally competent adult with no family
to be unemployed for very long there is
no reason for it at all zero because
your life is so supremely uncomplicated
and you have all the mobility in the
world come on can't keep a job there's
there's there are 16 year-olds out there
who have managed to keep a job
it takes me off I don't mean to yell at
you and I'm yelling at your son you
called your behalf cuz it just annoys me
the excuses people make I can't find it
I'll shut up yes you can you just don't
want it you don't want the job as well
you don't that's well that's the issue
okay I could I could walk into town I
could walk into town right now and I
could get 15 jobs easily have they're
not gonna be good jobs you know I mean
they're gonna they're gonna it's going
to be fast food it's gonna be working
behind a cash register it's not gonna be
fun it's gonna be stocking shelves it's
gonna be working in the back at Home
Depot it's gonna be those kind of jobs
but yeah I mean it unless you're living
in the middle of the wilderness aside
from that if you're living in a place
where there are stores and their retail
outlets all around like most people live
these days you could easily find a job
easily no problem so that's what I would
tell your deadbeat son all right thank
you for the question and thanks
everybody for watching and listening
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
cyber monday turns into psycho Monday
from the TV ads selling cheap consumer
goods to the politicians trying to sell
themselves we will examine all the
sociopathy then speaking of psychos the
deep state goes on offense before the
Inspector General releases his report on
the origins of the Russia investigation
can we the people beat the bureaucrats
all that and more check it out on the
Michael Nolt show